cher ne cherche pas à n'entendre que ce
que vous voulez entendre il ya une chose
très simple à faire vivre quand il ya
une promiscuité entre individus quel que
soit le lieu alors là je vous ai dit le
démarrage de l'épidémie en scandinavie
il est là c'est inéluctable les eaux des
barrages
une partie de l'accélération de
l'épidémie en italie du nord c'est les
stations de ski c'est clair aussi ça a
été démontrée ça veut pas dire que c'est
le seul facteur bien non il y en a
d'autres où ça a été les entreprises non
mais bien sûr à pattes ont fermé parce
que ce que ça veut dire c'est que toutes
les occasions où des individus sont
proches les uns des autres sans mesures
barrières il ya un risque c'est clair
c'est net et c'est inéluctable sous fait
des rêves l'aura été par exemple assure
maria que ça se passe dans une cafétéria
les curieux que ça se passe dans un
appartement que ça se passe dans un
mariage c'est la même chose
le maire a le pouvoir d emmanuel mais où
le préfet mais il ya eu des fermetures
dans le vin y avait beaucoup de
fermetures s'il vous plaît même à paris
manuel monter la pièce qui est le
propriétaire d'un bar qui s'appelle
l'avenir emmanuel 6 1 6 1 voilà si vous
êtes fermée pendant pendant trois quatre
cinq mois
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est la fin
pour vous de se terminer
faire mon commerce et sur pourrait tenir
comme un mois moi c'est un grand maximum
selon max vous entendez ça c'est un
mayari grand maximum à la trésorerie
sylvain maillard je sais qu'il va y
avoir des aides mais ils ont des frais
fixes
là on se parle on parle et on l'a vu à
le premier ministre de dire qu'il aurait
peut-être qu'un repos finement total
n'est pas exclue là si on repart pour
deux trois quatre mois
il ya des gens encore emmanuel y en a
plein qui nous regardent ça va être ça
va être une catastrophe arnage je pense
qu'on peut nous reprocher beaucoup de
choses probablement bien sûr et on est
je suis venu ici aussi pour y assurer la
tension on peut nous reprocher beaucoup
de choses je crois qu'on est dans la
première phase on a été on ne connaît
encore d aller au bal mandala renseignés
ils ont été là ils ont mis le paquet
pour on doit être à votre écoute je vous
je vous le redis on doit être à votre
écoute parce que vous avez raison c'est
nous c'est le gouvernement
qui fait fermer votre votre ego doit
être votée goût moi je suis pas dans la
discussion par non encore une fois vous
aurez raison parce que vous allez parler
avec émotion et c'est moi qu'on aurait
tort parce que je suis méchant titien
mais mais mais vous savez je suis chef
d'entreprise aussi ça que je fais les
deux chaudes et moi j'ai les mêmes
difficultés je peux avoir les mêmes
difficultés que les vôtres la seule
chose c'est que je crois que ce qui est
important c'est qu'on puisse réunir un
parent un par un vous n'avez pas les
mêmes difficultés que monsieur vous
n'aurez pas difficultés que les autres
vous avez dit que vous étiez tout à
l'heure vous avez 70 ans donnait 70 ans
peut-être vous avez une pension devait
sûrement pensionnés efforts sur nos
têtes donc peut-être vous êtes
propriétaire n'est pas un loyer par
exemple on doit peu 3d de façon
différente crédit que monsieur qui a un
crédit ou faut bloquer directement est
la banque allait faire ensemble trouver
l'un je paie le credo est de votre
crédit parfait mais qu' on puisse
trouver des solutions un par un on doit
vous aider on doit être à vos côtés de
celle à vous avez raison c'est notre
responsabilité d'être avec vous mais
pardon parce que de marne et sa part
gouverner c'est prendre des décisions
qui sont évidemment extrêmement relevé
où ferrer n'ont même jamais autant en
notre âme et solidaire avec le
gouvernement
solidaires les députés de la république
en marche solidaire avec le gouvernement
nous pensons qu'il faut des mesures
fortes